les pieds dans l'eau valient sur le dos
ces habitants de rerson sont obligés de
quitter leur maison ici l'eau a tout
emporté sur son passage
nous étions
dans une résidence privée là-bas vers le
milieu de la route
comme des milliers d'habitants en aval
du barrage ont du fuir certaines maisons
ont été emportées par les millions de
litres d'eau qui ont déferlé dans la
vallée d'autres tentent de sauver ce
qu'ils peuvent
la situation est critique si l'eau monte
encore nous perdrons notre maison on
amène nos affaires chez nos voisins qui
vivent dans des endroits plus élevés
qui a rapidement réuni son Conseil de
sécurité le président ukrainien pointe
directement du doigt Moscou
le fait que la Russie détruise le
réservoir de carrouska qui est d'une
importance critique en particulier pour
fournir de l'eau à la Crimée indique que
les occupants russes sont d'ores et déjà
réalisés qui devront fuir la Crimée
de son côté la Russie dénonce un acte de
sabotage délibéré de kievaux privés
d'eau la Crimée
occupé depuis 2014 à l'automne 2022
volody myril avait déjà averti d'un tel
scénario estimant alors que la rupture
du barrage serait une catastrophe à
grande échelle